[Music]
after months of waiting and endless
speculation that the trailer for the
fourth avengers movie has finally
arrived for one thing
the trailer reveals the title for the
feature as avengers end game confirming
previously leaked info
indicating that might be the case but
beyond that there's a world of mystery
to this footage
showing us our first official glimpse of
the marvel cinematic universe post
thanos's decimation you've already
watched and re-watched this thing about
a thousand times
so let's break down some of the small
details you might have missed in the
trailer for avengers endgame
thanos now retired to his quiet life as
a big purple space farmer has put up his
armor for good as an incredibly imposing
scarecrow you can actually see the
scarecrow in avengers infinity war
in the lower right corner of the frame
drawing the movie's ending sequence of
thanos looking over his crops towards
the shiny sun on some unknown world
but this image has some extra
significance you might not be aware of
in the six issue infinity gauntlet comic
book series which served as the
inspiration for the two-part infinity
war story the scarecrow
is a striking image from the final issue
in the comic the scarecrow appears to be
thanos's only company
when the heroes come upon it they regard
it as an empty shell of what was which
may imply some interesting twists in
store for the final showdown
between the avengers and thanos as for
thanos himself he's only seen briefly in
the trailer
running his hand over some plant life
with his burnt up infinity gauntlet
does he have the strength for a second
round we'll see after all
we're in the end game now
after sitting out the events of infinity
war jeremy renner's clint barton has
returned for the fourth avengers
adventure
and something is very different about
him he's got a new haircut a new samurai
inspired outfit
and he seems to be stomping the streets
of japan hunting down some sharp dressed
victims
and leaving them dead in the street for
some unknown end you alright clint
this is more than just a costume change
it's a whole new identity
one that natasha seems somewhat shocked
to say rumors have been swirling about
the meaning of clint's absent from
infinity war
since before the movie even came out the
prevailing theory has been that barton
sheds his old identity
and maybe even a little bit of his
morality when his entire family
presumably gets dusted at the end of
infinity war
we didn't see it go down on screen so we
don't know for sure if that's what
happened
but come on do you think clint is
booking flights to japan to go stab
people if he's got a wife and kids at
home
in a bittersweet twist it looks as
though tony stark has commandeered the
newest vessel
of the guardians of the galaxy the
benetar which took the place of the
milano after its destruction in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2.
of course not all is as bleak as it
first appears for one
tony does not seem to be alone on this
sad doomed trip across the universe
it looks like nebula is there with him
pitching a ride after her ship was
destroyed during her showdown with
thanos on titan her blue fingers can be
seen on someone's shoulder
probably tony's considering she's more
robot than mortal being at this point
thanks to thanos tinkering
it's possible that the lack of oxygen
and food on the ship isn't as big a deal
to her as it is to tony
for months and months rumors have
swelled about the avengers going back in
time
to undo the destruction thanos has
caused a theory supported by leaks
indicating that the production was
rebuilding sets from older movies
it's hard to think of any other reason
why cap would be looking down at a photo
of peggy with such significance unless
he was about to go and find her for some
reason
other set leaks have indicated that the
movie may have built a new set for camp
lehigh the boot camp in captain america
the first avenger where a pre-super
serum steve rogers first proved his
worth
the base located in new jersey was also
visited in the modern era in captain
america the winter soldier
and more importantly it was destroyed so
if the movie is taking us to camp lehigh
as the leaks suggest then it's probably
not going to be in the present day
and that would explain cap going back to
his outfit from the winter soldier
sort of like when star trek characters
have to go back in time and try their
best to blend in
so as to not screw up the time stream
wow it's a blink in your missing moment
but the avengers endgame trailer
revealed that sheree the woman who we
thought might be wakanda's last hope is
among the missing
during the sequence of bruce banner
looking at the avengers list of missing
people
the image of letitia wright's cherie can
briefly be seen among the presumed dead
with this we're meant to believe that
she dies off screen snapped into dust
just like her brother while the team's
intelligence has wrung about ant-man who
is indeed missing but not dead we have
no reason to believe that cherie made it
out alive but
while we're on the subject of ant-man
clint barton isn't the only avenger
making a triumphant return
now that most of the heavy hitters are
dead and dusted it's time to welcome
scott lang to the party
welcome to the party pal while natasha
and steve are moping around avengers hq
they get a video message from ant-man
who seems to be at the gates of the
facility
can you buzz me in that's exciting
enough but what's more exciting is the
gear that scott brought with him
what sorry my bad
last time we saw ant-man's ant van it
had been turned into a makeshift
laboratory kitted out with a portal to
the quantum realm in the post-credits
sequence of ant-man and the wasp scott
entered the quantum realm
and appeared to be stuck there with his
partners being dusted before they could
pull him back
scott sure looked doomed so what gives
right before scott jumped into the
quantum realm he got this warning from
the original wasp
and don't get sucked into a time vortex
we won't be able to save you
it seems pretty possible that scott used
a vortex to exit the realm depositing
himself in the future
and now he's brought the time travel
tech to avengers hq
who would have thought ant-man would be
so important when it came time to save
the world
probably this guy
[Music]